siamo su real royale royale e siamo con
thomas cosa devo fare qua mago va bene o
cj axis la prima persona che ho trovato
j ax dove sei
eccoti come mai tu mi spacci batte
royale ogni 5 minuti non lo so ne escono
più velocemente di quanto e colazioni
faccia nella mia vita che se l'autobus
in questione è una specie di zeppelin
rudd hanno rimesso un segnalino la
visura vedi il fascio di luce aspettai
non sono brava ma se lo vede anche senza
la luce del magnificat a321 io mi
lascerai dai andiamo sul giallo
allora ragazzi siccome io vengo a
conoscenza di questi giochi tramite
thomas che mi spaccia dei batteri al
come se fossero pacchetti di patatine
la cosa importante da sapere che non so
una mazza quindi se faccio schifo lo si
apre poi cadute e 3 casa33 com cosa vedo
ho fatto ora non si era aperto durante
tutto da un'ati stata una montagna
fortissimo e non si apre il paracadute
magari forse lear meloni piccolo errore
tecnico e fatti allora premi ze succede
una magia che l'h sul cavallo perfetto
viene incontro spiega c'è una cesta
quali sembra ritrovato un break plate e
una revolver ma sono un mago non posso
usare una revolver si può poi tranquillo
e io non sparo le magie magi e spara
c'è tantissima gente che ha forza ha
scelto una zona un po troppo poco
tranquilla per iniziare le magie cile ai
box a destra lo solo f c'è solo questo
orca vacca sommità superman pero restano
life quale raccoglie dentro le ceste le
magie va bene come facciamo qua
forse quando entrava aprirlo tempo ecco
se la struttura e magia o e le mie due
migliori e trovato club la madonna
allora una t scongela recuperi e vita
l'altra tv una palla di fuoco provarla
tranquillo l'altra cosa importante ecco
c'è un alfano ha fatto un'ottima storia
liu che botta
ho preso una volta niente siamo
diventati nasconde di collo questo vuol
dire nascondersi cosa stanno vedendo i
miei occhi thomas ma cos'è rimango ma
cos'è sta roba
niente con il secondo ragazzi è alto
meno di oggi fa vincere a cena o brava a
questo senti di cosa parlano
quello più brutto che abbia questa è la
forza in pratica è un'altra cosa unica
di questo master royal tutti gli premuto
e gli puoi dare delle delle cose da
craftare quanto ti manca per tenere di 0
c'è un mago qua grande ucciso grande
palla di fuoco e mo questa roba è qui
e ancora il venire fuori attenzione e
presentito per le armature con la è
quello che non prendi poi premere hicks
e lo puoi disincantare infatti se vuoi
la labilità l'arma leggendaria classe
apple forse ora signora si stanno
avvicinando
li vedo eccolo mancavano di cacciatore
cioè rimane soltanto lui ma vada
prendiamolo e oplà fortissimi o le
prendi e belle reti pure l'armatura che
c'è qua sai che c'è gente si pieni
veloci con la neo dg che li sopra sali
su volando ma non mi abituerò mai a ste
magie porca vacca
ecco la mia sappa ace la sales comandato
bisogna andare poi scusa a questa spara
proprio vice pescara pure le munizioni
sono infinite questo troppo amica ecco
perché è possibile che siamo usciti a
fare sette chili in un gioco che ho
acceso dieci minuti fatto io che sto
insegnando a giocare a questo ragazzo
quindi quando hai bisogno di vincere
partite chiamami ok allora grazie per la
tua prego se le premia prego dai voglio
la prima la prima partita la prima
vittoria subito per gioco nome afam
ecco la tirata a mano che tirata che la
tiro io in faccia vedi cominciamo
aspettano palalaforgia quando c'è la so
proprio dire che c'è qualcuno dentro che
sta creando cose quindi evidente che
aiuterebbe a memory non minori non mi
amor i nomi amorino memorie nome morì
quando a me
sono due maghi un e pollo l'altra qua da
me forse non mi uccide a bello mi ha
ucciso porca vacca arriva arriva di roma
colis
lo faremo perché un muro beccato cavolo
hai anche la storia si no
col demonio cuore che palle diciamo che
la prima l'ha tirata loro ecco quindi
quasi di mettere la crisi ci credevo di
altissimo nella prima ci credevo porca
che rosi c'è il sole che sta esplodendo
ma dove siamo in questo c'è una storia
il suo gioco credo gli ostelli che
volano che è via via via sempre andare
lì dove stiamo andando al lavoro è
cambiato un po zona così vediamo di
realtà si piace soprattutto perché non
si aprì paracadute mattini la facciata
per terra e fantastica stava a terra
come mi ricorda un film ma non riesco
ancora sai quanta roba affatto tipo
unico fighissimo spaccato la roccia
porca vacca siot atterriamo su pietro
che meglio dove andiamo qua porca vacca
non ci voglio credere ma negato amazon
prime il plant i protagonisti proteggimi
vado da amazon vai da amazon
buongiorno ragazzi in questo momento sto
proteggendolo ne mettiamo caso che
arrivi qualcuno a ucciderlo mentre lui
risponderci top
ragazzi scrivete nei commenti hashtag
altra cosa parte con la vedrà mai niente
comunque hashtag thomas for life ecco mi
plan morto
no nota posto sono morti tutti gli altri
abbiamo vinto c'è una cesta cena cesta
la al signorino giallo andiamo a
prenderci travi in arme leggendaria
dentro quella illuminata di giallo o
coltivate orca vacca indietro
ecco percorrere se li sta distraendo to
sparagli c'è un assassino che ha poca
vita un assassino è andato un pollo
arrivati aiuto preso qualche aiuto di
filippo lo citi pollici della barca è
ottimo non ha detto uccidere il porto ha
avuto dei problemi
va bene stato molto easy tensione mi sa
che questa è la vince porca va ragazzi
cioè deve mettere di nuovo devono
smetterla di queste cose sono nascosto
senti che si ammassano di cose vogliamo
partecipare al combattimento ed un
maghetto l'asi appena congelato quando
gli altri si mena riempire i pop corn e
guarda con la jolie
l'assassino se lo uccidiamo te la puoi
prendere senza doverla captare ma io
diventi visibile con la mia leggendaria
adesso ce la sentiamo vogliamo andarcene
io me la sento io me la sentirei ci
hanno un po vista porca vacca se colpito
si 630 io col bando occhio chiocchio un
apollo il mago è diventato un pollo
questa andata abbiamo un occhio qua
vieni su ce l'ha mai arrivati
ok cura di questi serve cioè sono
abbattute andato a prendere le cose
leggendarie se ti servono mancano
celasse ancora l'assassino 195 litri
sono verdi vai non non perdere perché
non ho ricaricato l'arma o che lo
diventerà mamma mia che ti manchi occhio
se non ha sovrastato nova
ma cosa vogliono mi ha preso parte
rimanente ma vaffan cuore va vicini se
se io parlo ma perché ho parlato
arrivano primi magheggio di nuovo una
mano ci sta ci sta
facciamo l'ultima dai 66 forti occhi
occhi occhio blu
mamma mia che schianto ho visto che cè
gente aspetta bisogna non è come quando
arriva un arrivo la tua sinistra dietro
vita dietro precedente dietro l'idea
ecco vede un ragazzo dentro la casa
dentro la casa bravissimo io volato in
faccia
buon 6 buon salvi signore
ok perfetto è durato molto 20 pure il
pollo d'oro più c'è qualcuno da me ok
sono nascosta ma dico 30 di questi
aspetti preso il mago bravo riso ma
venivamo ancora è stato il mago è
diventato un pollastro prima né
l'assassino è quanta vita aveva preso
ancora un colpo ancora un colpo
stiamo andiamo andiamo andiamo abbiamo
sparar di ok è collo anche lui bisogna
uccidere il mago sales così in qualche
stanza questa piano di sopra
nola oggi ha guardato lo giuro non c'è
non lo vedo mannaggia s'è nascosto bene
prenditi anche la staff leasing alla
sfir ecco la riva porca vacca la palla
di fuoco
ok è andato grandissima eco le più belle
macchia molin questa mi sà proprio di
una partita vinta ma provi a garda
la serbia è proprio lento globe c'è
gente a 345 un tizio lì davanti a noi
ecco lo vedo lontanissima prova spararli
qualcuno che pregiate sta volando per la
vaccara essere un po lontanucci
arrivederci sparano no non ti farà
nascondere ai lati pure usati le pozioni
la vedo scontrati alla forza adesso non
si capisce dai aspetta ma dai che sfiga
porca vacca mancato di mieri non proprio
il real torna quasi stabilità cioè la
cosa leggendari ce la faremo leggendaria
questa storia di creare cioè anche il
senso della vita leggendaria che è il
tattoo art amica c'è tutto leggendario
tutto il ristorante leggendaria
incredibile mi sa che questa qua di
nuovo mi sa che regala perdiamo presso
pace
mi sento proprio a letture di allora qua
siamo un po chiusi però forse si esce
salire da un cavallo è uguale a quello
discarica viene premuto un tasto
ma lui vola tutto facile approccio
e adesso c'è chi può e chi non può io
può ciechi ma io la cecchi paone occhio
che co anche se non tutto da me la
società mi sono nascosto un attimo 20
ragionamenti vedo sono a 339 è il loro
no loro dove suonando si stanno sparando
gli altri la cina dove messo a segnalare
lo sparando a uno di loro non prendo di
le scatole madonna kate
stanno sparando a mille dato un volto
già levato un botto mi pare che se mi
lasciano un po nell'euro
poi una volta mi stanno lasciando sì
stanno malmenando però non sono
tranquillo e l'ora e poi scendere la
traversata voce piangente dietro dietro
di te può che sono tranquillo e però tu
sei un po incasinata sotto sotto c'è
gente qua c'è gente qua viene
sottolineato registrato ieri stato ok mi
sono buttato ghiacciando mi è stato un
casino per questo è un botto di gente
non c'è semplicemente della gente arriva
uno
ok
no fai loro ok ok ma se non ha sbagliato
si celasse no
ok tranquillamente cuore se la faccia
rima nieri marino maledizione ci avevo
per il turismo
c'era tutto il set siamo arrivati ci
avevo creduto film presentato nel collo
per partita conclusa che peccato vabbè
dai terzi non è male ragazzi fare molto
episodio perché mi piacciono i cavalli
c'è senso ai colli anche che mi piace è
passato anche dal canale di thomas che
mettiamo in description bella ragazzi
non c'è un telecomando ragazzi
ricordatevi sostituzione da ragazzi
[Musica]